yeah kid super shows up we go back in
the swoop we get garbed the [ __ ] up yeah
all out here in the road we got the
jalebas or the jalabas whatever the [ __ ]
it's called I brought one outfit to Leba
so I probably need a Garb yeah and then
we need way more Moroccan merch than
what we have currently
[Music]
whichever one you have six of how much
is he asking for
whatever it is
the price your price don't buy price
and he's the best Tipper in the game you
don't know 350
wow yeah what's going on right now I was
working with them I was on their side I
was actually trying to destroy doug
because I don't want him to save any
money and make him feel good about
himself played himself
how much
425 it's good for good luck okay well no
I'm supposed to go under sorry 200.
we're already wearing it I don't think
we have much leverage I'll show you
Leverage
[Music]
for the good
[Music]
guys
oh my friend you're famous oh my God oh
my God
I am Captain America we're looking
absolutely beautiful Mark calls me
Captain America I thought that was a
great pun that's great that's you bro we
all go out to watch the game torrential
downpour yeah yes I mean it's never
rained in Morocco in the wild windy
country never one time it has it rained
never I thought it was a desert it was
and it wind ridiculous snakes flying
everywhere monkeys going [ __ ] crazy
it's like Wizard of Oz Wizard of Oz wins
like Jumanji joke and we had book seats
it's this huge outdoor Plaza there's one
little balcony thing where you can get
seats we found front row seats on the
balcony we're gonna watch this also
front row seats to what though to the
bat to the plaza but but where's the
game it's on a projector on the other
side of the square this big come on
we're talking about I was like yo we're
going to be kind of far from Michigan I
thought that [ __ ] I was like nah let me
not rough with others but I should have
said some we got we got [ __ ] on that
one yeah now we got [ __ ] no we had a
backup option which you wanted so you
can get an overhead view to shoot if
there were 40 000 people in the Square
that's also true it was a good it was
good planning until hurricane having a
backup yeah but what did we end up
watching it right in front of the giant
screen but uh listen so we go watch the
game torrential downpours second half it
miraculously stops raining yep Morocco
is playing absolutely unbelievable
losing one nothing but kind of a lucky
girl lucky ass goals six minutes into
the game whatever
the people in the Square start to fill
in yeah the energy in the square is
crazy everyone watching it all over
dominating this right side of the ball
this guy Hakimi God bless him good so
[ __ ] good I mean they got everybody
on lock yeah great shots on gold
non-stop shots on the shots on goal
cannot convert Mark what the [ __ ]
happened I don't know I don't know
Barack was playing out of their minds
amazing game I played France I think one
of the first times African team made it
to the semifinals the first one that
made it the first Arab country to make
well Arab I don't know Arab nation is
what I heard berbers they're berbers
Moroccans like to be called African
North Africa well the first North
African the first Muslim country first
mcgrebby's that's for sure facts
Maghrib
a magarib my point is we we went there
for this Underdog Story it did not end
up happening and if every time you
followed an underdog they succeeded then
they wouldn't be underdogs would they
yeah but we're going to keep following
these [ __ ] underdogs we're gonna keep
rooting for the impossible because it is
so Sensational and the energy is amazing
around it I'm really glad that we went
it sucks that we didn't get the exact
result yeah but maybe maybe
maybe it's not about the results it's
about the friends you make along the way
it's about the journey Al that was
beautiful the adventure about the
adventure man we out here for the
adventure
you know what I'm saying
hey Doug let's do a shot though
can we do a little can we do a little
shotsky come on come on shout out to
Yeager
yo also I I do want to say this right
because
listen
this is all of my second oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] come on bro my bad okay I do want
to say this [ __ ] because
we've had Jaeger here on the on the
podcast you've never seen Jaeger you
know displayed like that and we were
talking to we were talking to Jaeger
right and you know they were saying that
they want to do some stuff with us
now Jaeger
sponsored this adventure that we went on
to the Morocco they've actually asked me
not to say that they did but I do want
to say I do want to talk about why why
it's important that we say what that did
um they really just wanted this to be
organic they want to just put the
[ __ ] bottle right there and what I'm
doing right now might breach contract
but we'll work on that with them but uh
but what I think it's really important
because when we were talking to Jaeger
um and column kid super is sponsored by
Jager and he was the one who's like yo
you gotta see these guys they have this
crazy idea they want to go to Qatar et
cetera I've never worked with a company
that has given
so much creative wiggle room and control
to myself or our group before literally
the day of we don't even have it
confirmed yeah we switch the plans yeah
originally we were just gonna do a watch
party here yeah and they wanted to
sponsor it and we literally said to them
yo we got a crazy idea we want to go on
adventures that's what the [ __ ] this
podcast about we like taking not a [ __ ]
with that but we like taking these
moments to go have these incredible
experiences and we want to switch it
from a live stream we want to go to
[ __ ] Morocco are you down to do it
you know how many positions there are on
the corporate chain that you have to get
you know a a confirmation from approval
from constantly like they just came back
and immediately just said yeah yeah and
I think it's important to point that out
because ideally we deliver an incredible
product ideally you guys you know [ __ ]
with it but I loved working with a
company that just lets us make cool [ __ ]
and I think that we made a way cooler
thing a live stream would have been
great we would have done something
awesome but it's different than going to
Africa for 36 [ __ ] hours and being
part of this amazing adventure so I
generally speaking I would you know just
put them here and have the uh what is it
called when you just have a product
placement yeah do the product placement
but I want to compliment them and their
their employees and just the people
there that like really just are
investing in creators even like yeah
yeah it's like it was really cool to do
these things and I hope that we have
delivered something that blows them away
yeah I really I really do hope that
because I want to continue doing these
Adventures we're going to continue doing
them no matter what the reality is we
were on our way to [ __ ] Morocco not
knowing if they were going to say yes or
not and then we landed because remember
there's no internet we're buying these
tickets we're out
and then we don't have the on the plane
there's seven hours where we're like
are we paying for this you know what I
mean and then Landing to that
confirmation is just [ __ ] cool and I
just really salute them I think it's
awesome that they do it and I hope more
brands do that and I hope we can blow
these things up in a way that other
brands go hey maybe we gotta let
creators create yeah
I hope that letting creators create
makes the brand more popular and then
other brands start going hey let's stop
getting in the way so much red tape and
like Executives giving notes and [ __ ]
yeah they literally told me not to do
this I just want to point this out right
now so maybe this is the best way to
start the relationship that's an exact
thing because we don't want to be too
forced we want you to ask we just want
to be organic but I do think that this
is the most authentic way to put it I
thought it was so [ __ ] cool that they
did this yeah so and the stuff they do
with kids super is sick too if you don't
know kid super obviously he's like a
fashion designer artist creative guy in
New York like from New York it just
makes the decision for talent and they
are sponsoring him to make a space it's
amazing it's amazing out there in
Brooklyn matter of fact if you'd like to
know more about kid super
look at this what's up everybody it's
Captain America here in Morocco your boy
Chelsea we're just in New York doing a
podcast but we're lucky enough to have
one of my favorite creatives one of the
great New York creative minds we got kid
super not in the [ __ ] building
and the [ __ ] Riyadh and uh
we're out here watching the game
together and I thought that it was only
right that we give some of the people at
home a little glimpse into the genius
that is kid super I'm saying all these
great things about him please do not uh
be embarrassed when I say make sure you
hold that [ __ ] mic up to your mouth
these are microphones we are doing it
third world is third world right now
we're keeping a very third world with
our first world cell phones uh kids
super you're the [ __ ] man thank you
so much for being out here with us uh
three flights
right three flights to get here we we we
call him he's in Brazil
and we say we're going to the Morocco
France game in Morocco actually I will
give you credit we were like should we
go see it in France and then and kid
super goes it would be way crazier to
see it in Morocco so you kind of did put
that out there and the other thing so we
were debating if we wanted to go to
Qatar if we wanted to do all these stuff
because all of a sudden Schultz is a
die-hard soccer fan yes this is this is
yeah and little do you know but me and
Mark play soccer together on the kids
super team weekly uh when he's feeling
fit and getting slender and so he was
like oh I don't really did you put in
that goalie when he gained off that way
no he's like yeah I'm beefing up for
what you're a podcast but
um then we were deciding if we were
going to go to Qatar or Morocco and
Schultz wanted the culture wanted to
experience the people and fun fact my
mom was actually born in Morocco
so is worth the 24 hour flight from
Brazil to go to all around the world to
get here and I landed about four hours
ago the games in three hours yeah and if
Morocco wins we're the most Geniuses of
all time I mean this is I mean Morocco's
gonna win I'm saying this right now we
don't know what's gonna happen Barack is
going to win the energy is here we have
the colonized taking out the colonizer
it only makes sense it is only right
everyone at home you might be calling me
[ __ ] idiots once you know the actual
score because it's not coming out until
next week but I just wanted to let you
know that the positivity not only is
there a storm coming to friend there's a
storm here like you feel the energy
something's going down we damn near made
a [ __ ] side Talk video in the middle
of the shoot okay this guy with like
four teeth in his whole mouth look like
a Jack-o-Lantern just started screaming
[ __ ] the French we probably have to cut
that and I was to maintain relationship
even there he wasn't even there exactly
exactly
but we're also all in the exact same
outfits yes and we're ready what's also
good I mean on my own personal note
soccer has brought me all across the
world and I know Schultz has just become
a die-hard soccer fan but it's amazing
that something brings all these
different people together so I was in
Brazil because of soccer now I'm in
Morocco because of soccer and I'm gonna
end up getting out of the way to the
other Camp yeah I'm gonna end up in
Qatar which Schultz has depending on the
game today and his wife situation it is
my wife's it's not even my sister it's
our anniversary uh the the the final
game is our anniversary we're gonna end
up going to the [ __ ] final one I'll
say right now if when Morocco wins today
when Morocco went to say we have to
continue to bestow that good luck
because you are the good luck charm
that's what I told them I told I
wouldn't negotiate in the shook I said
listen the discount you give me is the
luck you give to team Morocco which
you've been he has a great haggling
technique it's really really hard yeah
and then tips them heavy yeah so I tip
them back up to the price that they
wanted more or less it's like you know
when like uh they react so well they
love it they love it they love it they
love it yeah because they they brutalize
me that's really what they like about it
yeah but no it's Catch and Release you
know what I mean yeah yeah there's some
scientific about it I play the game you
know anyway
um I think you're [ __ ] genius uh for
those people who might not know you just
yet
um it's so weird to call you a clothing
designer because how do I say it it's
like you you might hate this you might
love this call you a clothing designer
is like calling like Diddy a music
producer
do you know where it's like I also know
you from all these other crazy creative
things I just feel like your creative
outlet has been pressed upon clothing
but then I get to see you make
animations I get to see you do cool
things when you did the painting thing
remember
I I don't even I'm gonna butcher it by
describing it just go YouTube What Would
You YouTube kids super painting fashion
show but basically I did this fashion
show where each look had a painting
assigned with it and I'd painted all the
uh 23 paintings and the last look was a
painting but she walks out of the
painting and it makes for real so you
see her face in the painting you're like
oh I see a human face that's cool it's
behind a a big canvas and a painting
blah blah blah it is whatever I've maybe
seen this before in every Scooby-Doo
episode right the bad person is in the
wall and their eyes are like following
you and then all of a sudden the model
walks through the painting and the
painting drapes over them and becomes
the outfit
it was genius it took a lot of trial and
error and what was cool is like there
wasn't this like behind this like crazy
machine behind it or if we hired a
production company to do it I really
built the whole thing and like the
Brooklyn studio and we failed a lot yeah
can you tell me about this Brooklyn
Studio that Mark talks about non-stop so
I've I built this state of the art
[ __ ] studio in SoHo I finally get us
out of Brooklyn think I'm doing this
poor kid a favor and he can't wait to
get back to Brooklyn to go to your
[ __ ] Studio this is true this is true
and it is funny because you that I mean
he tried really hard on his Studio
yeah I did a good job you did do a good
job the kid super has always had a
physical space so before I had a dorm
room that I converted into a store that
everyone came and was
buying out of my dorm room and then I
got kicked out because it was a store
then I got this space in Brooklyn that
was really small and I lived in the back
of a store then the top two floors moved
out and all my friends moved in and I
owned in parentheses this building in in
Brooklyn and then we kind of outgrew
that and now we just signed the lease to
a 10 000 square foot building
unbelievable in Brooklyn which he's from
New York City as well so he understands
how difficult it is to find a space of
that size yeah I got it because of covid
and I've been now trying to make it a
magical place with recording studios
storefront podcast
uh not for me for whoever in his team
wants because I don't know if uh it's
safe for me to get on a podcast but part
of it has been with brand sponsorships
that have supported it and one of those
being Jagermeister who we've done
countless projects with yeah
um what I loved about this is and I pay
attention I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
lie because obviously we you know have a
lot of people who we work with sponsor
the Pod Etc I pay very close attention
to to brands that seek out true
creatives right like not just chasing
numbers numbers are very important we
got to sell things that's how the game
works but like seeking out people who
are making creative things and like
supporting them in that endeavor because
I think those people actually really get
the the value and Equity behind that and
that's I mean Jagermeister supported me
to almost five four years ago when I was
really didn't have the numbers didn't
have Paris fashion week didn't have and
it was just they respected how hard I
was trying at something and I respected
how hard like our first project we
worked on we did a gallery show and they
said do I want sponsorship I said sure
they said how many people do you think
are going to come to your gallery I said
100 a thousand people ended up coming to
my painting gallery show but she came
with 10 bartenders 10 cocktails they're
all named after each painting yeah and I
was like what the [ __ ] you tried so hard
and she was like what the [ __ ] a
thousand people yeah so that was where
we started our relationship and so now
not only it's been amazing for me and
growing and I literally couldn't have
done it without brand sponsorships but
also I put I say hey Schultz is a person
you actually should support yeah and
they without a doubt gave you the
supported like like I got this in what
two days it was unbelievable it was it
was so cool and corporations do not work
like this yes I I want to be very clear
corporates do not work like this and we
work with some [ __ ] awesome ones but
for two days for us to go yeah we're
gonna live stream it and then two days
later we go yep I think we might go to
Morocco we got the tickets to go to
Morocco the same day we left right so on
the plane we're messaging them we're
like yo is it cool if we go to Morocco
and watch the and watch the game they on
the plane we get the message back and
they're like give me like half an hour
for approval and we're like okay
well I was thinking I was texting uh
Jamil I was like Jamil didn't come
I'm like what happened to Jaeger pulls
can I be honest with you we we didn't
have internet on the plane yeah so we
didn't know that this was a go until we
landed
and no so hey shout outs to you Jaeger
we appreciate your commitment but I love
that I thought it was cool that they
were down they just wanted to do
creative [ __ ] and um well it's also
people are Behind These Brands which if
you often forget and we're in a society
now where the creatives have a ton of
power right you prove that hugely on
your Netflix special so it's in their
best interests or your Netflix quality
special there we go Netflix quality
special Mike to face Netflix quality
special but what I'm saying is now it's
in their best interest so yeah they're
good people but it's in their best
interest to support yeah yeah it's cool
to let you do what you can do because
you know better than anyone else right
so I think and now we're in Morocco so
it worked out that's what I'm saying
like just let us go on a [ __ ]
Adventure I remember when I was talking
to them I was like listen let us create
those kinds of weekends those kinds of
events like we will make it happen I
know I seem like a lunatic we just
facetimed her right now and we're both
look like we just came out of Sahara
yeah we're lunatics but sometimes being
a lunatic is fun and you get to do cool
[ __ ]
um so they they this is I thought was
really interesting because they sent a
package over right and uh they said the
bags over and they're the jerseys that
you created yes right so you did a
jersey four Team USA I did a track suit
for Team USA well obviously it's World
Cup season and everyone knows that I'm
the biggest soccer fan ever and new
soccer fan new soccer fan
and brand brand new soccer fan I just
wanted to be very clear everybody at
home brand new when he plays FIFA he
plays with Real Madrid
Manchester United Okay come on go keep
going let's see your teams Atletico
Madrid okay you're
you're all right well you spent her we
all know you studied abroad I look like
I knew some things right there okay LA
Galaxy okay that's a horrible turn dude
no I shouldn't go on the list I quit
Tottenham Hotspurs sometimes cold
uh what man city
not bad Chelsea
Chelsea City
other countries you got another stranger
man Italy
uh Juventus
I think he's he's which do you say
you're more knowledgeable soccer or UFC
soccer you kicked that out no no UFC I
probably know a little bit more but
after you're so engaged you're the
number one UFC journalist as they say
the fact that you almost said soccer is
crazy no I mean listen listen I I
consider you someone who knows a lot
about UFC but I'm I'm thinking you're
good at boxing which you never bring up
yeah yeah I don't talk about that at all
out of all the things that you brag
about I gotta keep the streets honest
yeah he's a pretty good I mean from the
highlights I see that was a great uh
what is it underhanded compliment what
you just did right there you're like
you're great at boxing I was like oh
thanks and then you're like out of all
the things you brag about if you think
that you would talk about the thing that
you're decent at that's what I'm saying
yeah it's kind of like how you tip and
buy this guy right here this guy is a
[ __ ] problem except for the
sponsorship immediately okay there you
go take a look at that tell me what
happened with this jersey right now
before we go eat some tagine okay so
this is actually one of the paintings
from the fashion show well this is a
painting yeah it's a soccer player okay
so
um the what team
the of the the painting yeah what team
is that guy just uh random you don't
know what team it is it was just it was
just pictures did you see that oh you
don't know what team that is more like
you know like a representative of a
moment does that sound like some
[ __ ] you would say if you knew
nothing about [ __ ] soccer doesn't
doesn't that sound like okay so break
this down so you picked a random guy it
kind of looks like me and you you put
him on it was a soccer painting
Jagermeister which is actually quite
interesting was one of the first if not
the first they don't like to say it
first because whatever but Brands to
ever sponsor a soccer team and that
first jersey looked very similar to this
with ah true God so it was a reference
because when I went to the headquarters
I try to tie in everything I do into
soccer and when they said they were the
first sponsor I was like whoa done
that's game only cool and so now you're
it's illegal for an alcohol company to
sponsor uh
a team really yeah why is that because
uh Qatar brought up all the rest of them
but what about a non-alcoholic company
like could o'doul sponsor a team yeah
probably I actually don't know the exact
rules seems like you don't know a lot
about soccer buddy
because there used to be very big
branded alcohol companies and now
there's not well betting companies which
also is pretty illegal right yeah even
though we love them yeah we love them we
love them they're great
but yeah I think the Jersey's [ __ ]
fire I think it's great that you get to
do these things and just go on these
Adventures now the question is when do
we get when do we get out I want my name
on the back and the number exactly yeah
what number would I be
for how your personality uh or how I
play what position would I play
obviously well I've never seen Striker I
would say like you could also be an uh
like center-back that kind of just two
studs tackles to set the pace seems like
you're saying I'm not an offensive
player no you're more you set the tone
can I also strike and set this home yeah
but that's not as much maybe a forward
Striker and also you
so good at boxing
I think you're more of like a brute
type
am I like the enforcer yeah
I'm there to protect messy yeah because
Missy's little you're not a little okay
okay okay so are you more of like um
but the way that you is like not you
don't know like how to really have good
touch that was you dude you're trying to
flip it on me I don't think that's good
but it's good that you knew that Pepe
who Pepe that's one of your top faves
come on dude I know all these things no
I see
like a Roberto Carlos like what position
does Roberto Carlos play uh back
but then he still runs besides
come on it's not bad Roberto Carlos is
the best at his position ever no no what
do I really think you are Andres Iniesta
that's a good one I think I see you like
dude
I see I see you Andres Iniesta
impossible take the ball away from you
controlling the game Crazy assists
leading the attack but when it comes to
defense you're not really about that
life I'm very much not about that life
like
if you knew how
you how God do you think but the problem
is if you spend too much time on defense
because you can't have fun
that's not as like energized when you
get the ball but um I I am that type I'm
more of a uh a little bit more attacking
yeah than than uh scoring and setting up
or I'm much better setting up setting up
yeah much better so if you had to make a
basketball analogy for who you were
um I'm I'm pretty bad at basketball to
be honest what about like a John
Stockton the assist King I all I know
him as just a white the white guy yeah
on the Dream Team yeah she's like all
right that guy dude he was so Anonymous
well Steve Nash was a great shooter yeah
okay from distance but they hear a great
story about the Dream Team in there in
Barcelona he was the only player that
could just walk around the streets like
he was just he goes I would just go with
my family and I'd be wearing the dream
team shirt that had my own face on it
with the other guys and people will walk
up have no [ __ ] how big is he you
might better than him I'm probably about
the same size
but yeah I see seven people up yeah
Andres in the SL all day dude
um who's like a great passer in the
modern day that's Chris Paul okay yeah
Chris Paul I mean he's like the ultimate
point guard assist guy and who are you
who is my comparison yeah
aren't you also okay at basketball
I mean look I don't want to brag no no
but who is my comparison being the
problem is I was never a great shooter
from distance
you just close good shooter I was like
what's called mid-range I I was okay but
I could get to the basket so I would get
to the basket and then dish I was like
an assist guy but get to the basket but
if I could shoot man that would have
been a little bit of a game changer I'm
trying to pick my yeah this is a fun
game who is your professional
counterpart yeah I like uh also do you
know who Modric is yeah I was just for
Croatia yeah that's also a little bit
and then there's a player James
Rodriguez he's Colombian he was on Real
Madrid he had the greatest World Cup
last World Cup um
but uh yeah I would play it a little bit
that's what you think well who I want to
now who who is okay that's the dream is
Mildred is the dream no I'm not uh or
James Madrid's Fabs Madrid if you had to
pick an American player
um oh Geo Reina oh fire the son of yeah
Claudia who played I guess yeah
professionally that's why he grew up all
over
um is actually fire yes the US team's
gonna be really good and that's what we
have to start planning for is the World
Cup yeah we've been saying the US team
is going to be good for about two
decades now yeah but it's happening
22. that's true that's true they're all
going to be and they're finally not all
German that was crazy yeah yeah not that
there's anything wrong now there's
anything wrong
German coach literally was like America
sucks if you have any strand of American
I'm signing up the team literally
couldn't speak English that was crazy
and it wasn't like they were great Urban
players he just thought like Americans
were so so bad I know how messed up
you're like this American kid is a
dedicated his entire life to soccer and
this guy doesn't speak English there's a
lot of that I mean yeah there's a
different uh there's a lot of random
people that switch teams yeah yeah
guitars was trying to do that oh really
yeah because they knew they were gonna
have it for 10 years so they just were
trying to go around the world to like
nationalize am I close to your face also
I just want to point out that
if kid super dies in Qatar at the finals
just no he did say that on this podcast
just know that there is proof of him
saying that on the podcast I just want
to point that out there
um listen listen we have a tagine to get
to we do and we have a game to support
and we have history to be made if he
said it if when when Morocco wins
his anniversary for one year will be in
his favorite country in the world Qatar
Qatar Qatar Qatar we're going to Qatar I
haven't told my wife this yet but if
we're sorry when when Morocco wins the
storm is coming France when Morocco wins
we're going to guitar my wife will
probably be in Dubai
reliving some real housewives [ __ ] but
we will be in Qatar is she likes soccer
yeah
isn't she like her Dad what's he saying
oh no her dad is a huge fan he's so
happy that I'm here okay like he's like
I'm so glad that also potentially Shultz
will come to Paris oh lock it in can we
talk about it yeah can we talk about it
you can't talk about the other thing
okay there's a lot of things that we're
okay we're gonna keep you abreast on all
the kids kid super fashion show in Paris
in January yeah he for some reason wants
stand-up comedy to be a part of it huge
mistake but it's okay you've got to let
creatives create and um I'm going there
dressed like this
[Laughter]
okay uh let's throw it back to the guys
in America